En algún momento, esas conductas son potenciadas por una cultura
que promueve el beneficio personal sobre el beneficio colectivo.
Por lo tanto, si elegimos desplazar la corrupción,
debemos comenzar antes de que se arraigue.
Debemos intervenir temprano.
No sé qué es lo que sucede en sus países
pero en el mío
la juventud nos liderará hacia el futuro.
Hoy en día en Kenia, el 80 % de la población es menor de 35 años.
Pero, según ellos, tienen valores opuestos.
El 58 % de los jóvenes de Kenia dijo recientemente
que haría cualquier cosa para ganar dinero.
El 45 % dijo
que la corrupción es una herramienta legítima
para hacer negocios.
El 73 %
dijo que no está dispuesto a defender lo que cree
por miedo a un posible castigo.
Lo que aprendí gracias a mi madre
hace unos años
es acerca del "poder que tiene cada individuo",
que cada uno de nosotros puede ser un agente potencial del cambio
y que, juntos, somos una fuerza,
que si nos unimos, podemos cambiar la situación
y ningún problema resulta irresoluble.
Mi madre entendía esto de manera tan profunda
que era el centro de su labor.
Cambiar una cultura requiere paciencia, perseverancia y compromiso,
y es una tarea muy lenta y profunda.
Pero si queremos cambiar una cultura debemos comenzar a trabajar.
Y, luego de que mi madre falleciera, creamos una fundación en su nombre
para hacer exactamente eso
pero trabajamos con jóvenes y niños
para empezar a construir el carácter y el liderazgo personal
para infundir determinación e integridad.
Pero combatir a la corrupción no es tan fácil
como decir que la corrupción es mala.
Bien, tenemos tres estrategias que estamos implementando
y que creemos que pueden ser implementadas en cualquier comunidad educativa.
Primero, debemos comprender el porqué:
¿Por qué la corrupción existe en primer lugar?
¿La llamamos por lo que es -un robo-
o la encubrimos con otras palabras?
Cuando los niños sepan cómo se ve y cómo se siente
lidiar con la corrupción,
probablemente, cuando enfrenten un dilema en el futuro,
lidien con ello de la manera que se les haya enseñado.
En segundo lugar, debemos enseñar explícitamente a crear un carácter.
Bien, esto debe parecer obvio
pero un niño que demuestra una mentalidad de crecimiento
y autocontrol
es seguro de sí mismo.
Y un niño seguro de sí mismo probablemente defienda sus convicciones.
En tercer lugar, tenemos que construir el liderazgo personal temprano
para enseñarles cómo
desafiar a la corrupción cuando estén ante ella,
cómo se siente defenderse y ser tenido en cuenta
y, para mí, establecer la conexión más importante
entre el sufrimiento humano por un lado
y, por el otro, la corrupción, la avaricia y el egoísmo.
Debemos creer en nuestra capacidad
para crear el futuro que deseamos;
cada uno de nosotros puede aportar su grano de arena.
Los jóvenes deben creer
en la posibilidad de una nueva realidad.
La corrupción, el cambio climático,
el colapso del ecosistema, la pérdida de biodiversidad
-- todas estas cuestiones requieren una dirección --
Y en palabras de Baba Dioum, de Senegal:
"Al final,
conservaremos
solo lo que amemos,
amaremos
solo lo que entendamos
y entenderemos
solo lo que se nos enseñe".
Gracias.
(Aplausos)